الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا الان
حيث قالت وسائل اعلام روسيه ان الجيش
الروسي بدا هجوما على مواقع للجيش
الاوكراني في محور كوبيانسك بمقاطعه
خاركيف على الجانب الروسي اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع تصديها لزورق مسير اوكراني في
البحر الاسود كان في طريقه الى شبه جزيره
القرم التطورات الميدانيه اذا نتابعها من
زبروجيا مع مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام
وتصريحات الجانب الروسي نتابع
من موسكو مع مراسل الجزيره امين رغامي
مرحبا بكما ابدا معك الياس كرام بالتطورات
الميدانيه من
زبرج بالفعل محمد اولا الجيش الاوكراني
يتحدث عن تقدم في محور باخم ويقول بانه
يواصل هجومه وانه احرز تقدما جزئيا اضافيا
قرب بلدتي يشيفا
واندريس عليهما في الايام الاخيره ولكنه
في نفس الوقت يقول بانه ما زال يصد هجمات
من جانب القوات المسلحه الروسيه التي
تحاول استعاده هذه المواقع من ناحيه اخرى
كل المواقع الشرقيه كل جبهه الشرق اي
اقليم دومباس ومناطق اقليم خاركيف الجيش
الاوكراني في موقع دفاع في في كوبيانسك في
ليمان في اندريفا في مارينكا في شختار وفي
غيرها من محاور القتال لكن هنا في محور
زبروجيا الجيش الاوكراني ايضا يتحدث عن ان
هجومه متواصل نحو ميلتو بول وانه يحرز
تقدما على الاقل في النواحي الغربيه لبير
فيفيه وراوي رغم انه يقول بانه ما زال يصد
محاولات من جانب القوات المسلحه الروسيه
لاعاده السيطره على مواقع فقدها في فقدتها
في الايام الاخيره عند راكوتين من ناحيه
اخرى الجيش الروسي واضح بانه يحاول فتح
جبهات اخرى من اجل اشغال القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه في هذا المحور واجبارها على
دفع تعزيزات الى منطقه كوبيانسك في الشمال
مثلا في خاركيف او في مناطقه في باخ موت
وفي غيرها من مناطق الدنباس وايضا اشغاله
على هذا المحور الطويل الممتد من الجهه
الجنوبيه الغربيه للدم باس وحتى محور
زبروجيا ذلك ان القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
تقول بانها تصد هجمات للقوات المسلحه
الروسيه عند بلده نوفو د اريفا واوجينا
هذه المواقع البعيده نسبيا عن المحور محور
الهجوم ال الرئيسي هنا في منطقه زبروجيا
حيث يواصل الجيش الاوكراني الدفعه بمزيد
من التعزيزات العسكريه وبالتالي هنالك
محاولات من جانب القوات الروسيه لاشغالها
في فتح جبهات وهجمات مختلفه على طول هذه
الجبهه الممتده على مئات الكيلو مترات
فيما يواصل الجيش الروسي ايضا توجيه ضربات
للجيش الاوكراني في الخطوط الخلفيه لذلك
نحن نرى ان نحو اكثر من 20 بلده اوكرانيه
على محور زبرو تتعرض لضربات وهجمات
صاروخيه ومدفعيه وغارات جويه كاوري خوف
وماليه تك ماشكا ونوفو بروكو بيفك هذه
البلدات التي تحولت الى خطوط خلفيه للقوات
الاكرانيه دا عن ذلك الهجمات الصاروخيه
متواصله ايضا على المدن الاوكرانيه في
خاركيف هذا الهجوم الذي اودى بحياه اشخاص
وادى الى اصابات ايضا في صفوف المدنيين
هذا يدفع المستوى السياسي في اوكرانيا الى
المطالبه
مزيد من الدفاعات الصاروخيه من الحلفاء وم
الوسائط الدفاعيه لحمايه المدن والبلدات
الاوكرانيه فيما يطالب الجانب السياسي
ويقول بان هذه جرائم حرب يرتكبها الروس في
هذه الح هذه العمليات امين ما الذي يقال
في وسائل الاعلام الروسيه حول هذا الهجوم
على كوبيانسك
نعم محمد واضح من خلال ما نشرته وسائل
الاعلام الروسيه بمختلف توجهاتها على ان
هناك زياده في زخم العمليات العسكريه في
اتجاه كوبيانسك وتحقيق الجيش الروسي لتقدم
في محيط مدينه كوبيانسك وتحديدا في الجهه
الشماليه الشرقيه من المدينه مع طبعا
مواصله توجيه ضربات الى مواقع الجيش
الاوكراني في ذلك المحور بمقاطعه خاركيف
سواء بالمدفعيه الثقي او براجمات الصواريخ
والطيران الحربي مقابل هذا التوجه يبدو ان
الجيش او التقدم يبدو ان الجيش الروسي في
باقي المحاور ياخذ موقعا دفاعيا اليوم
الوزاره وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تحدثت في
بيانها الاسبوعي عن حصيله وجرد ل حصيله
العمليات العسكريه خلال اسبوع تحدثت عن
صد عشرات من الهجمات الاوكرانيه في مختلف
المحاور جنوبا من خرسون مرورا بزبرو
جيا وايضا بدونس وصولا الى لوغانسك وايضا
خاركيف في الشمال
ويحاول الجيش الروسي من خلال هذه البيانات
والارقام مواصله توجيه ضربات باسلحه عاليه
الدق كما تقول الوزاره لمواقع تجمع الجيش
الاوكراني داخل العمق الاوكراني اضافه الى
مخازن الذخيره والاسلحه وورشات انتاج
المسيرات كما اعلنت عن ذلك الوزاره اليوم
وايضا تركيب وتجميع المعدات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه الوزاره تتحدث في هذا البيان
الذي صدر اليوم عن اسقاط 320 مسيره
اوكرانيه خلال اسبوع اضافه الى اعتراض نحو
40 صاروخا من طرازات مختلفه من بينها طبعا
هاي مرس امريكيه الصنع وتكبيد الجيش
الاوكراني كما قال المتحدث باسم الوزاره
خسائر كبيره في العتاد والقوات خاصه في
محور دونيسك الجنوبي وهنا الحديث عن تلك
المنطقه التي تربط بين دونيسك وايضا زبارو
ومحيط مدينه دونيسك ايضا في تلك الجبهه
المشتعله طبعا كل هذه التطورات العسكريه
تقابلها تصريحات سياسيه ادلى بها اليوم
نائب رئيس او نائب سكرتير مجلس الامن
الروسي دمتري مدوف الذي قال بان روسيا لا
ترفض مسار الحوار لكن هناك شرط واحد
للدخول لاي حوار ويتمثل في القبول وتقبل
الوقائع والحقائق الميدانيه الجديده وقال
بان الغرب بدا يفقد قوته بحسب تعبيره
وايضا قدرته على مواصله امداد اوكرانيا
بالاموال والاسلحه وقال بان هدف ذلك الزخم
الغربي هو اضعاف روسيا وجرها الى حد ان
تتخلى عن مطالبها وقال بان طبعا هناك ايضا
محاولات لاعطاء الجانب الاوكراني الجيش
الاوكراني على الميدان محاوله لاستجماع
قواته واعاده نشر اسلحته على الارض وبان
روسيا مستعده دائما دائما للدخول في اي
مفاوضات ومسار حواري بحسب قمي شكرا جزي لك
واشكر من زبروجيا ايضا الياس كرام شكرا
لكما